So what's happening here Mike?
Here it's a big fire.
All the wheat is burning.
Step one, cabinets.
Yes, open.
Find the pieces.
Small adapter, fire gun.
So bring the fire gun to Joao.
Fire gun is a hand to Joao.
Do you want to put a fire gun on the hose?
Boom, one person fire gun.
Mike is setting the adapters.
Outlets.
Make sure it's full of seals.
Ready?
That was quick.
Throttle is on now.
You did the clutch and the orange button.
The throttle on.
So no more than 15,000.
And how do you fix that?
Yeah, you can see.
Now it goes low.
When you push it right.
And it goes up.
It's the orange one, yeah?
Yeah, this one.
This is no function.
This is only for communication to the backside.
Normally here's a microphone.
On the backside is a speaker.
And then they have normally a CB phone
so they can talk together.
OK, so then.
Yeah, he has a license for that.
He drives a caterpillar inside fires
because he was a soldier in Portugal.
And all the soldiers have the option to train these.
But they must do it every year.
Yeah, yeah.
That is why I ask him.
He's a soldier.
That is why I ask him to stay with us.
He can also knows a little bit about that.
Be careful.
Now it's full power.
In the search.
Nice area here.
Sergeant search.
Me neither.
Sergeant.
Let's go.
Oh, that is nice.
Hold it.
Careful with the mic.
He wants us.
I don't care.
Careful with John's mic.
Sorry.
Only one.
Sorry, sorry.